[Musique]
le maïs irrigué en plein mois d'août à
mauvaise réputation premier coupable
quand on parle de semences gourmandes en
eau pourtant c'est le blé le glouton de
l'histoire cette céréale est la plus
cultivée en Beauce
fin avril dans le Loiret les premiers
arrêtés de restriction d'usage de l'eau
sont tombées mauvais signe pour les
irigans de la région la question de
l'eau est pourtant une préoccupation du
quotidien pour eux en économie et
efficience
à partir de du 22 avril faudrait que
j'irai que cette parcelle en l'absence
de pluie bien sûr
Pascal est agriculteur spécialisé en
semence potagère et en céréales sur ces
150 hectares en Beauce il en héritent
130 et il s'appuie sur les conseils de
la plateforme nattirig
le stade du blé correspond à ce
qu'indique à ce qu'indicat la tablette
donc là on est au
on est au 1er noeud on sent le on sent
le nœud là du blé on arrive au deuxième
nœud voilà donc
le stade est important parce que plus
plus le stade augmente plus la
consommation d'eau augmente et donc il
faut que ce soit il faut que ce soit en
phase avec ce que dit la tablette
sur la plateforme les agriculteurs
peuvent entrer les spécificités de leur
parcelle type de sol variétés de
semences état de croissance de la plante
le tout combiné aux données
pluviométriques pour savoir quand et où
irriguer ça permet de prioriser
lorsqu'il a plusieurs parcelles de
Pascal il a plusieurs parcelles de blé
il y a des parcelles qui sont en solde
plus profond celle-là elles peuvent
attendre par contre celle-ci peut pas
attendre donc il va décider celle là et
puis il fera les autres après
avec le changement climatique il y a
beaucoup de données qui rentrent en jeu
il y a des décalages de pluviométrie de
température etc etc et tous ces
paramètres là
un agriculteur sans outil qui va l'aider
à avoir plus clair dans dans ces
changements là ça va être compliqué donc
c'est notre mission aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment rendre l'expertise agronomique
accessible au plus grand nombre possible
d'agriculteurs
l'idée des concepteurs est d'être au
plus proche de la réalité du terrain
bientôt naitirique pourra intégrer les
données des stations météo personnelles
des agriculteurs pour encore plus de
précisions dans l'irrigation l'objectif
c'est effectivement de faire en sorte
que une goutte d'eau d'irrigation elle
soit le mieux utilisée possible et
qu'elle soit le plus efficiente possible
donc ça passe évidemment par ces outils
d'aide à la décision qu'on essaye de
divulguer et de promouvoir bon après il
y a d'autres il y a d'autres appuis pour
améliorer l'efficience c'est les outils
d'irrigation en tant que tel c'est les
rampes les rampes d'irrigations les
enrouleurs qui sont plus sophistiqués
qu'ils n'étaient etc etc mais l'outil de
la décision c'est le premier outil à
utiliser on a quelques essais qui
montrent notamment qu'on a pu
économiser notamment sur des cultures de
maïs par exemple de l'ordre de 15 à 20
voire 25% d'eau donc c'est quand même
pas c'est quand même pas neutre c'est
quand même très intéressant
économiser l'eau chez les irrigans c'est
un vaste chantier d'autant que les
volumes d'eau attribuaient cette année
sont en baisse
ils sont calculés d'une année sur
l'autre en fonction du niveau de
remplissage de la nappe de Beauce cet
hiver la nappe a pu se remplir seulement
à 66% de son niveau habituel Pascal qui
avait 147 000 mètres cubes d'eau l'année
dernière n'aura droit qu'à 97000 mètres
cubes d'eau cette année face à la
contrainte Pascal a déjà adapté sa
pratique
quand j'ai préparé mon assolement
j'avais prévu de faire du maïs jusque
là-bas au vert il y a jusqu'à la
parcelle de poids mais compte tenu de
des volumes d'eau que nous allons voir
cette année j'ai décidé de mettre une
culture de tournesol à côté à la place
du maïs qui sera beaucoup moins qui sera
moins gourmande en nous
la Chambre d'Agriculture du Loiret
souhaite développer l'outil net iRig au
niveau national dans le département la
plateforme n'a pas encore rencontré le
succès escompté sur les 2 millilirigans
du département seul 140 l'utilise au
quotidien
[Musique]
économiser l'eau c'est aussi choisir des
semences appropriées à Ouzouer le marché
les ingénieurs agronomes d'Arvalis
cherchent la petite graine
[Musique]
on est sur un site dans une parcelle
agriculteur où on a installé un
dispositif de contrôle du stress
hydrique donc en fait on a des toits
roulants qui vont permettre de couvrir
des expérimentations végétales donc en
grande culture blettendre blé dur maïs
orge etc etc et qui vont permettre en
fait de couper les pluies de manière
artificielle et de créer des scénarios
de stress hydrique sur les cultures
les portiques équipées de capteurs
prennent des mesures tout au long de la
croissance de la plante pour voir son
comportement face au manque d'eau
une plante se retrouve en stress
hydrique lorsqu'elle va avoir du mal à
puiser l'eau du sol et en fait l'eau du
sol on la caractérise avec ce qu'on
appelle le réservoir utile et il y a une
partie de ce réservoir utile qui est
facilement utilisé par les plantes donc
lorsqu'elles sont installées elles
puisent l'eau tout va bien elles peuvent
transpirer et au fur et à mesure de la
campagne si on a des conditions qui vont
être séchantes ou avoir des cultures qui
vont avoir des problèmes d'implantation
notamment ou d'enracinement les plantes
peuvent se retrouver en réserve de
survie donc c'est à dire que l'eau elle
est plus difficilement trouvable par les
plantes elles vont du coup diminuer
leurs photosynthèse leur transpiration
et donc ça peut provoquer des manques de
production
les résultats des tests réalisés sur le
site d'Arvalis permettent de
sélectionner les variétés les plus
robustes à la sécheresse informations
utiles aussi bien aux agriculteurs que
ce Nancy
[Musique]
alors là on arrive au premier plan d'eau
et on va aller voir le deuxième
en Indre-et-Loire Christian est
agriculteur céréalier il a créé deux
retenues d'eau pour irriguer ses
parcelles
au deuxième plan d'eau qu'on a fait en
1992 avec on était 6 associés on s'est
réuni pour faire ça
en barrant un fossé régulièrement inondé
il a créé une retenue d'eau de 16
hectares l'autre de 19
on s'aperçoit avec 76 que les rendements
sont en d'Annecy donc il faut qu'on ait
des rendements réguliers pour pérenniser
des revenus réguliers et répondre à un
marché aussi pour se stabiliser les prix
d'un marché quoi on a créé en fait une
ressource qui n'existait pas avant on
aurait pu faire aussi l'irrigation par
des forages on s'est dit non créons les
retenues pour faire une ressource
nouvelle
aujourd'hui le principe même de stocker
l'eau fait polémique pour preuve notre
agriculteur ne souhaite pas qu'on
identifie l'emplacement de ces deux
retenues colinaires pourtant ce ne sont
pas ces types de retenue qui sont les
plus décriés par les écologistes mais
quand on aborde la question de l'eau les
irrigans se sentent montrés du doigt
on arrose quand on a besoin de quand la
plante a besoin d'eau en fait pas pour
le plaisir le Béaba notre métier c'est
quand même de produire pour l'humanité
on le produit pas pour manger nos
produits on produit pour que les autres
aient de quoi manger
et de quoi se nourrir on répond à des
marchés qui sont existants si nous on
les fait pas ça sera d'autres qui les
feront on sera obligé d'importer des
produits qui ne seront pas peut-être
aussi cinq que ce que l'on peut faire en
France
dans le Cher le collectif bassine non
merci Berry s'écrit en 2021 pour lutter
contre l'implantation de nouvelles
réserves d'eau pour l'agriculture pour
les militants les retenus colinaires ne
posent pas problème ils s'insurgent
contre le fait de pomper de l'eau d'une
nappe ou d'une rivière pour remplir une
réserve artificielle c'est une
aberration de Pompée dans les nappes
phréatiques pour mettre de l'eau en
surface on sait que l'eau elle est mieux
retenue dans le sol seulement on fait
tout pour qu'elle n'arrive pas dans le
sol alors les trois bassines qu'il y a
actuellement dans le Cher c'est des
petites bassines mais on sait que si on
accepte ça après il y aura des méga
bassines partout
et en fait l'eau c'est un bien commun et
ça on est en train de l'oublier
c'est retenu de substitution n'ont rien
d'illégal elles ont été financées par
l'agence de la loi Bretagne pourtant
nous n'avons pas eu l'autorisation de
les filmer
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de là à Clément en
Sologne Frédéric Bidot a lui aussi sa
réserve d'eau il l'a creusé après les
inondations de 2016 pour drainer son sol
et se marier défend un autre modèle
d'agriculture celui de la paysannerie
c'est un modèle agricole qui qui est
très vertueux qui prend tout en compte
l'environnement le côté social et le
les débouchés de proximité
pour lui le modèle agricole actuel doit
changer pour être plus économe en eau
comment on va utiliser cette eau qui va
utiliser cette eau et dans quel but
certains petits maraîchers qui
voudraient s'installer dans notre région
n'ont pas l'autorisation de pouvoir
aller chercher cette eau pour travailler
alors que le voisin céréalier qui sont
sur l'agrobusiness voir sur la la
production pour de l'énergie on ces
droits d'eau qu'on ne peut pas leur
enlever il faut va falloir un jour
remettre à plat tout ça et qu'on
redirige l'eau vers ce qu'on estime être
indispensable et aujourd'hui mettre de
l'eau dans un champ pour envoyer des
céréales à l'autre bout du monde c'est
comme si on envoyait notre eau à l'autre
bout du monde
puis de la moitié du blé tendre français
est envoyé à l'étranger et 45% du maïs
destiné à nourrir les animaux d'élevage
par en Europe
[Musique]
alors ça va vous en trouvez justement je
viens de trouver un nom d'objet
Frédéric Thomas est agriculteur et à
Grenoble il a une passion pour les vers
de terre chez lui pas de la bourre ce
sont les lombrics qui aèrent la terre et
pour les nourrir Frédéric pratique la
technique du couvert végétal sur cette
parcelle féverolles et poids ont pu
pousser pendant l'hiver quand les
plantes fonctionnent qu'en ce moment on
a de la photosynthèse c'est il y a du
soleil qui arrive sur les feuilles c'est
faut imaginer que c'est des panneaux
solaires donc en fait ça ça fait du
sucre et les plantes font de la
végétation mais en même temps on voit
avec leurs racines du sucre dans le sol
qui nourrit l'activité biologique ça
fait de la biomasse qui pourra
éventuellement nourrir des animaux et
nourrir le sol après et puis comme c'est
des légumineuses ça rentre de l'azote
si les couverts nourrissent la terre ils
permettent aussi de garder l'eau dans le
sol en été il limite l'évaporation et
garde la terre au frais
on va se retrouver avec un sol qui va
gagner en perméabilité donc ça veut dire
que l'eau quand elle va arriver elle va
bien rentrer dans le sol donc en fait
l'eau même des pluies conséquentes l'eau
va rentrer dans le sol et après ici un
peu tendance à stagner un petit peu dans
sur la zone d'argile mais au moins elle
est pas en train de ruisseler partir
directement donc accueil de l'eau
améliorée infiltration amélioré stockage
de l'eau grâce à la matière organique et
la profondeur du sol
non ver de terre encore une fois la
profondeur des racines améliorer
pour Frédéric Thomas qu’importe la
taille des parcelles les couverts
végétaux c'est que du bonus
beaucoup de gens même dans des régions
très sèches
pensent et ils ont raison que le couvert
va consommer de l'eau effectivement une
plante pour pousser consomme de l'eau
mais en même temps
il va consommer de l'eau pour permettre
d'en économiser plus tard alors bien sûr
il y a des prix de semences ça va coûter
du gasoil dans le tracteur du tracteur
ça va coûter du temps mais en fait il y
a un retour sur investissement et il
faut regarder ce retour sur
investissement alors le retour sur
investissement c'est la minimisation du
travail qu'on va faire c'est
l'augmentation du taux de matière
organique qui va mieux stocker l'eau
c'est l'amélioration de la structure qui
va faire que les plantes vont pouvoir
s'enraciner plus profond ça va être
l'alimentation de l'activité biologique
ça va être apporté une diversité de
plantes et qui va apporter une diversité
d'insectes et d'activité biologique sur
l'exploitation
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
propose depuis longtemps des solutions
pour économiser l'eau elle est
d'ailleurs reconnue et pratiquée par
certains agriculteurs dans le monde
l'agriculture s'adapte depuis des années
au manque d'eau et aux périodes de
sécheresse plus fréquentes si certains
pensent que l'avenir est dans la
recherche sur les croisements de
semences d'autres souhaitent revoir
notre modèle agricole des solutions
existent encore faut-il qu'elles
rencontrent leur public
[Musique]